l'automne c'est la saison des vendanges
c'est aussi la saison de la rentrée
théâtrale à paris donc guy bedos à
partir de mardi à l'olympia après un
détour par le théâtre dans la résistible
ascension d'arthur oui de bertold brecht
à guy bedos qui va donc retrouver le one
man show comme ne dirais pas jacques
toubon sur une scène qu'il a partagé il
y a deux ans avec muriel robin comme
dirait l'événement du jeudi que je cite
le pitre est encore à venir petit
extrait tourné à créteil de ce spectacle
d'un homme qui se complaît dans l'
agacement chez gas gas gas gas à je sais
je sais que je gagne chez gas gas gas
gas gas gas et ziva ce jésus aussi agacé
secret d'un état aux quartiers en
difficulté francheval de veyrinas celle
ci cela burgy douvres fois dans des
émissions elle va faire un tabac dans
les quartiers en dit
bonjour c'est bon deuxième place alors
les jeunes
non c'est moi c'est cette partie de polo
baba qu'est-ce que tu casses les
couilles toi qui sais c'est la st
patrick wyatt paulo s'échange comme tous
les jours du bar tabac après b 12e
pastaga pour rendre la maison d'étape et
braque ou parce que dans la rue aux
[ __ ] et un noir de plus il sortait du
cinéma n'en fasse même en prenant sa
propre os mobile est il avait l'air de
la folie
un joyeux triste sinistre à limerzel
elle m'offre une canne de randonnée
cette conne avec une gourde accrochés
aux mecs c'est elle la gourde qui sait
quoi que je vais me taper lescar est de
la roche de solutré pour remplacer
l'autre belle mère